all right lima all right welcome back
again
thank you thank you for having me we
haven't seen you in a while
yeah
so
we finally after how many months now
it's been like
it's been since nine months or something
april may
so we have the autopsy results for
amanda yes we do which just came a
couple days ago uh tell me what uh what
you know
yeah so the reason that it took so long
is because there was a lot of lack of
documentation
because amanda was homeless
and so basically what they used was they
did the autopsy they looked at her
medical records and then
larry and i also sent in
your videos to kind of show
her condition from the drug use and the
the beatings that she took and we also
had some some photographs
um
and so i'm just going to read it word
for word of what we got um the cause of
death was marked as a seizure disorder
amanda never had seizures prior to being
homeless
and
they believed that it was post-traumatic
seizure
epilepsy but they couldn't mark it as
post-traumatic epilepsy because of a
lack of evidence so they couldn't tell
if the seizures
are from
past drug use or traumatic brain injury
from the assault since the assaults were
not well documented
and then in brackets they put police
reports or hospital records
and so they just marked it as a seizure
disorder
if they had gone the route of doing
post-traumatic epilepsy if the
um
if the traumatic brain injury and the
assaults were well documented they would
have most likely marked it as a homicide
so
um
that was a major wake-up call for all of
us because
it basically illustrates what we were
saying in the last video that people
shouldn't be allowed to be homeless and
that
you know in amanda's case
the fact that she was using that she was
allowed to use drugs for so long and
that she was
abused and that none of that a lot of it
wasn't reported or documented
um these people are in danger and it's
not okay to just
you
know like let them be because at the end
of the day they really don't know how to
help themselves
so
there is a lot of things that i think a
lot of people
would be mind blown to know and i think
one of the things that we talked about
last time or just you and i over the
phone is how crazy it is that i have all
this information and i feel like it's
common sense but when i talk to you
about it you're always so surprised so
um it costs us for each homeless person
it costs about a hundred thousand seven
hundred and fifty nine dollars to keep
one homeless person on the street for a
year
um
so the reason that the costs are so high
how much was it
a hundred thousand seven hundred and
fifty nine dollars that's the average of
one homeless person on the street for a
year wow
so
um those costs are
you know a jail
getting picked up getting put in jail
released the police being called
ambulance overdoses hospitalizations
and on and on
so the homeless are high consumers of
public resources so a lot of our tax
dollars ends up
going to
you know pay for them basically to
remain on the street and the best case
of this was a man called
they called him million dollar murray
his name was
murray burr and he um
accumulated over a million dollars in
resources in the state of nevada
and ultimately he died homeless on the
street
so this is a major problem i've had a
lot of people write to me and tell me
like
you know we love what you do we support
what you do but unfortunately we don't
think that you're going to be successful
because there's so many people making
billions of dollars in this industry and
um you know the big players in this
don't don't want people to get better
and
i completely disagree with that
if you actually look at like for example
california there's uh as of 2020 there
was over a hundred and sixty thousand
documented homeless people
in the state
um so that if we do absolutely nothing
that's the cause that costs us uh 16
billion 100 million dollars like way
over that number um to do absolutely
nothing at all
so
a lot of the issue with mental health is
that it's an invisible problem until now
you know
nobody's really
a lot of money is being poured into the
issue but the relapse rates are so high
and then people just get so severe that
they end up in amanda's condition
another thing i want to point out is
amanda was receiving social security
disability insurance she was receiving
about seven almost seven hundred dollars
a month
and so if you look at the money that was
being given to her as a check
obviously it wasn't doing her very much
good
you know
if we could take the
those funds and we can
spread them out and scale what we did
for amanda it would end up costing the
state about 32 000
per person
um to house feed and give them mental
health support where they would end up
in a situation like amanda where she was
going back to school
so you spoke about in one of the other
videos recently
about how the brain is affected by
addiction
yes that was so interesting can you talk
about that again definitely so last time
we talked we were talking about how if
you looked at a brain spect image you
would see little holes in the brain and
those holes are not actual holes they're
they're areas where blood is not flowing
um so one thing that i really wanted to
point out is that you can actually see
dementia in your 20s
you can see the
the brain start to decay in your 20s
and
especially in amanda's case where there
was so much damage done to her brain and
so many others
an addiction can do that
you know the the big problem with
helping a lot of the people that you see
on my on my videos or people like that
is the amount of money that's required
yeah and you're and you're working on
something that might somehow help and
help others that need help with mental
issues right absolutely and fundraising
is a full-time
you know it's a full-time thing
um it takes a lot of time and then also
a lot of people don't have
a lot of money to put behind something
when they're struggling so we came up
with a supplement
and so again focusing on nutrition first
focusing on brain healing
and so it's called brain rescue and it
has about 40
vital nutrition
nutrients for
mental health just a nutritional boost
for your brain
and
the proceeds of that go to buy one gift
one so for every box we sell we donate
one to someone in need
and then the remaining proceeds go
towards hiring more people to respond to
all the inquiries that we get and then
pushing out
the scholarship program so um i'm not
sure if you saw the
last video i put up of amanda from this
funeral
um okay so i
um i made a funeral i made a video of
the funeral
like basically a celebration of amanda's
life for the gofundme donors and for all
of the people that helped
uh helped with amanda's care and so in
that video i talked about how i renamed
the scholarship program after amanda and
so the proceeds of the supplements go
towards um
the scholarship program the scholarship
program is what amanda was part of
exactly she was the first first person
you chose for that exactly and so this
is a way of adding value to people so
they can put their nutrition first they
can take care of their brain and their
you know healing and making the decision
to go to rehab shouldn't be the only
thing you focus on um when you go to
treatment and
you have a severe addiction or brain
like or um eating disorder mental health
issue um you know your brain is in a
position where it can't absorb therapy
and then when you're malnourished even
if you get medication you don't absorb
the medications the same way because you
know your your body just doesn't
function the same so this is just a way
to boost um to boost outcomes to give
you a nutritional boost and ultimately
to
have a formula where we're not always
asking for donations we're actually able
to sell something and then the proceeds
of that goes to helping more people so
um i'm not big on promoting things on my
channel but in this case i think the the
end result could be helping
yeah somebody like like like chris or
rebecca or a lot of there's a long long
list of people from my channel and
outside my channel that could benefit
from this definitely definitely and um
yeah and it would open up so many doors
because at the end of the day it's just
a money problem it's just about paying
for treatment
and then for the people that wanted more
insight into what amanda was receiving
um i uploaded her last interview that
her and i did together
and then um
you know us talking about kind of like
the issues that amanda saw with the
30-day programs and then
i also have the um like a little snippet
of
what her virtual reality treatment was
like so we filmed a little bit of the
session all right so i'll i'll leave a
little what is your is it on your
instagram
it's on youtube but you can find the
links to everything where would people
be able to find that lima from aura
everything is lima from aura lima from
aura from aura okay and then i'll leave
a link for that supplement that you're
yeah so you guys can pre-order it now
and then the proceeds go towards the
scholarship program that's wonderful the
scholarship program is what helped
amanda so beautifully so yeah so maybe
maybe there'll be others that we can do
i hope i hope so it would be a
a big honor to be able to do this with
someone else
i mean mental health is the biggest
issue behind addiction anyway
i believe i think you do too how do we
address the mental health that's
such a problem for so many here
yeah so homelessness is not a housing
issue as we discussed last time and uh
one of the solutions that los angeles is
currently working on
is buying up a bunch of condos with
views and giving them to homeless people
so if amanda was getting
you know collecting a check of
unemployment monthly and it wasn't doing
her much good and then giving these
homeless people
housing but not really providing support
that's probably one of the biggest
issues because you're just hiding the
problem you're not really resolving it
and
since the 1980s nothing's really changed
within mental health care psychiatry is
essentially a pseudoscience
if we're just going based off of
self-reporting and we're not doing any
further investigation so when you go to
a doctor for a physical health issue
they're going to do blood work and
x-rays and they're going to investigate
before they diagnose and treat you if
you go to someone for a mental health
condition they're going to ask you
questions they're going to have someone
describe how they're feeling and that
person might not necessarily even know
how to describe how they're feeling and
then they're going to end up diagnosing
you and treating you based off of what
you said and that's initially like the
core issue of what we're trying to
change we're trying to push this
you know
like
we're trying to really push change in
the mental health industry for people to
start investigating further and giving
additional data and an additional
investigation before just diagnosing and
prescribing and medications are just a
band-aid solution they're not the actual
issue a lot of these people that you
talk to like their stories
are heartbreaking and horrifying
and a lot of times it's these people's
first times verbalizing their traumas to
somebody they don't really talk to
anybody and you give them this safe
space where they feel like they can
share
um
but that's that's really why therapy is
so important because
when you hold something in it becomes
this deep dark secret and it becomes the
reason that you're just not good enough
like someone can have a drink and put it
down and someone needs that drink and
the person that needs that drink is a
person that feels like they're not okay
unless they have that extra something
they're not good enough they don't like
the way that they feel about themselves
and the difference between the healthy
brain
what i call a trauma brain is that the
healthy brain experiences an act
and the trauma brain is so you did bad
versus you are bad you know and so a lot
of the people that you see on
um
you know on the streets they have
they have very low self-esteem and
they've been completely shaped by their
experiences and giving them medication
to numb that pain
is just a very short-term solution to a
much bigger crisis
and i think that you know showing what
we did for amanda
and showing that it is possible with you
know even the most extreme cases and
i think one thing that people are not
familiar with about me is that amanda's
not the first case that i've worked with
i've worked with a lot of high-profile
people and
you know for hippoly i don't share
any of the names or you know i can't
share any of those people's stories but
i've dealt with some very complex cases
and you and i decided to team up and
teach people how to do it for themselves
and kind of document the process of how
we can help anybody
and i think that like
you know i'm very much an introverted
person i don't like to be the center of
attention and i
i i have to force myself to make these
videos and
um you know put myself out there and
it's really because i want people to
know what i know and i think that it's
so important
for people to understand the problem
because
adam grant
is a professor at wharton
university and he always says that
success is about contribution not
competition
and
you know
i can't change the world by myself i
can't change the mental health care
industry by myself i can talk about it
and i can teach people but unless we all
decide that this is
important to us and that we're all going
to unite together and we're going to
change and we're going to push a change
in an industry that's stuck in the way
that it is and doesn't want to change
right now because no one's really
introduced a solution you know all of
our solutions right now are problem
focused they focus on the immediate
problem there's a bunch of tents in the
street how do we like
you know clear the streets out let's put
them in housing you know no it seems
like what we're doing now is
trying to cure a drug addiction or
homelessness
they don't really solve the problem
whereas if we somehow fix the mental
health problems all these problems would
go away absolutely and it's as simple as
that
but yeah i guess the last thing that i
would want to say is that um
you know i'm really working on hiring
more people so that i can respond to all
of the emails that i get so um i get
about like a thousand messages whether
it be like instagram or emails or
whatever
from people saying like hey my son or my
daughter or my you know parent
needs help and here's a story and i
desperately feel for those people and i
really want to help them and
i have someone that i work with that
that's making a spreadsheet of
everybody's contact information and
we're working on
you know bringing in more people to be
able to help us but that takes funding
so
i'm working on that on my end you know
so i just want everyone to know that the
people that are reaching out to me i am
going to continue to
you know respond i try my best to
respond to everyone and if i missed your
message to please keep reaching out
because
we will eventually get to it and once i
have more people then
you know it's a priority for me the
reason that i'm doing this is because
everything that i did for amanda i want
to be able to build a bigger team to do
for everybody because it shouldn't be a
privilege to get care
all right well it's nice to get some
closure finally to amanda's
story i was starting to wonder what was
going on after
about six months of
yeah waiting
but
it all makes sense and i think there's
lots there's still a lot we can learn
from
from all of this definitely
definitely i think it's really just
about mental health
yeah
that's not gonna be easy solution
yeah well
it is if the money's there you know
so
if
i can help anybody if they can pay for
treatment if you can pay for treatment
it's you know like a snap of a finger i
can heal that person
um but when you say pay for treatment
that's not 30 thousand only thing that
that's the only thing that's standing
between people getting yeah but that's
not like 30 30 or 40 000
no it's a significant amount and so a
lot of people reached out and they're
like oh
why can't she help her sisters well
my sisters would cost me like 50 000
times too like a hundred thousand
dollars a month and
that's why it's so important for me like
i'm actually
in a way i have a lot of gratitude if i
was able to pay for my sister's care and
if we were very affluent then i wouldn't
care to help anybody else because i
wouldn't understand the problem the way
i do
but
helping my sisters
being able to scale care being able to
get insurance companies to cover this
treatment means that i can also help
everybody means that i have to change
the industry and the way the healthcare
system works
to be able to to push my sisters through
all right lima thank you so much for
coming in thank you mark for having me
great seeing you again thank you so much
bye
you